so first game for today against oh
bcker yes I've had that
a lot Brazil I've
never played the vi aha wow I guess that's
okay Benoni yes well I
played D4 instead of the usual Springer
F3 let's see what happens
comes around and
now we have received here
and
Benoni sämisch miix
so säisch variant Kön
indisch with F3 I played that before
and hope that I can still
get to grips with the position, it's been
a while since I had that on
the board
yes JA5 is normal
To get counterplay in a position like this,
so the knight comes back into the game via F2
on H1, he just shouldn't
stay J, it all seems pretty
normal. F4 is certainly
interesting now and I think if I
can do it, I should do it
back now  D7 and the next
black move will almost certainly
be F5 so King A1 because I assume
that at some point I will open the ginie. The
question is whether you take it straight away. I
'll take it
straight away. It's
surprising that he now thinks about it for a longer time.
Rook F5 doesn't actually look
like that  as if it
were okay, well,
that's the question of how
best to
position yourself here or whether you do it directly.
I'll try to open the gel line directly with G3. I still have the habaun
as protection if it doesn't have anything left,
so if you do it now  Put everything on the gel line
yes probably not good
for that purpose first of all he can
of course stand a bit wobbly on E3
so well B5 no could be an idea
but at the moment that would also be a
yes would be a pawn sacrifice and I could do
it  Maybe ignore it and
just keep going with the Ginie.
Overall, I have to say that I've
never really understood this position.
Again, somehow it always seems to me
like it
's strange for
Black, but well,
somehow you always have it  Still
playing,
how do you get
on with this here? He ca
n't do so much. I'll just
take this B5 story out for
a while.
What you'd really like to
do would be to put it somewhere in D4,
so if  The b-pawn here
would distract the c-pawn, well, okay, he
stands on the e-file first,
so now the question is maybe even
bishop D3 and queen C2 an idea, I
know it's not difficult then
knight G4 might be an
issue but it works  Dangerous for Black
no okay I'll try that
knight H5 I have rook
H3 yes I always have to watch out for
tricks no black is active enough that
he can somehow always trix around
yes he takes this one under
fire yes yes
of course that's true well
I don't know  I wonder if I
want to play but D5 hung once,
at least I think it's a very difficult
position
Bishop
H6 I'm wondering
Knight H3 G5 is an idea
Rook G5 looks interesting too,
maybe it'll work again, well I don't
have much
time again, that's what I thought  I take here and
G6 as an idea at least
has this idea F3 chess checkers F3 chess
has of course
stupid
so D6 is hanging but now this
h g well I think I can still
take D6 but then it would
fall I first take the six then
I take that one  still
hitting
yes I've probably
lost control we this position is also
really difficult in that at a
time like this
check
well it's 100% clear somehow it's
still not
everything I still have the d pawn
if I don't go checkmate or something like that
check knight F4
yes, I
still have to bet on the pawn here,
the position is maybe
even just fine,
but
h
well, positionally it's probably okay,
everything is
totally familiar,
but I just
wasted too much time
is often really too difficult for
both of them